this is a dangerous violent sex offender
a double rapist once known as Adam
Graham and here is the same person now
identifying as a woman Isla Bryson a
predator who's been detained in a
women's prison the reality is this
double rapist this Beast is in a woman's
prison right now we think it's wrong
this is Scotland's only dedicated female
jail the place where Isla Bryson has
been kept in segregation but the case
has caused a major row and put pressure
on officials to think again I can
confirm to Parliament that this prisoner
will not be incarcerated at Clintonville
women's prison and I hope that provides
Assurance to the public presiding
officer not least to the victims in this
particular case
within hours of that intervention by
Scotland's first Minister the serial
rapist was removed from the all-female
prison Sky News understands Isla Bryson
will serve the rest of her time behind
bars in an all-male Wing there are
currently 15 trans people in Scotland's
prisons and bosses say each case is risk
assessed on its own merits
a moment to reflect from Charities who
support rape victims I think for other
trans women who are in the female estate
they could also have been at risk by
this this rape has been put in the
female estate so I don't think this is
an issue about trans prisoners I think
this is an issue about a rapist and
whether or not it's appropriate to put a
rapist into women's prison
Isla Bryson's time in the women's prison
may now be over but The Rao is not Conor
Gillis Sky News Edinburgh